all right so we're about to dive into
this episode where Ryan and I talked
about baggage we talked about letting go
of the past we talked about entering
relationships with past baggage it was a
conversation I really enjoyed but before
we get into that Ryan's not here to
record this intro with me because
yesterday the day I'm recording this he
broke his back
snowboarding broke five of his
transverse processes on his lumbar spine
and well outside of Missoula Montana so
I don't have any updates for you other
than he went to the emergency room and
he was able to walk in there and he was
able to leave and he is fine so far he
reports to me that he is in the most
pain he's ever been in and that's a lot
coming from him because he is literally
the the most durable person that I know
and so man if you want to tweet him do
that tell him to get well soon
I'm sure he'll be back in no time I'll
be wearing all kinds of braces or he'll
he'll probably skateboard right in here
the reason I wanted to record this intro
I was hopefully going to do it with Ryan
but but that's okay that we're not doing
it together is we're making some changes
to the podcast if you didn't catch this
last episode last episode we talked
about collectibles and toward the end we
talked about how we're making some a
shift in the podcast and so I think it's
a pretty exciting news and the feedback
we've gotten so far has been amazing
talking about it with our patreon
supporters and on social media etc so in
March 2019 which is not too far around
the corner the minimalist podcast the
popular free public version that you are
listening to right now and your podcast
player or or maybe you're watching this
on YouTube this podcast the minimalist
podcast is changing its format just just
slightly in fact it's not even a real
format change the format itself is going
to stay the same we're just going to
attenuate the the main podcast a little
bit so that we can make our podcast we
can produce more meaningful creation
we want to make it a little bit more
intimate and private and personal as
well and we're gonna do that over on
patreon so let's talk about why we're
making this change well first off there
are some topics that we want to discuss
semi privately in front of a a small
empathetic understanding group of people
sort of conversations that we would have
with close friends or family just
trusted trusted people in our lives and
because our patreon audience we were on
patreon with a few thousand people over
there that audience those subscribers
are people who support our work the most
we believe that those people are the
best people to have some sort of
conversations where we are a little bit
more loose with what we talk about
conversations we may not want to have in
front of the hundreds of thousands or
millions of people who listen to the
main podcast so we're gonna do some
longer form conversations over on
patreon starting in March because we
want to be able to think out loud in
front of a small group of people who are
willing to give us the the leeway that
we need to grow and fail and change our
minds in real time and we need to be
able to talk about things like our
failed habits our family lives our
struggles our personal relationships our
emotions and our insecurities without
fear of judgment public ridicule and we
believe that patreon for us is the best
place for us to delve into sensitive
subjects difficult discussions in our
normal unique brand of silly tomfoolery
and patreon is also the best way for us
to keep this podcast 100% advertisement
free both the main feed and the
minimalists private podcast that we have
over on patreon so we want to keep our
podcast 200% advertisement free and the
way we we fund it to pay for the studio
space to pay for podcast Shawn and
Jordan no more filming it is with with
patreon and so next month February 2019
the minimalist podcast is taking a month
off well we're going to take a month off
of the
the free public feed so we're just
taking some time off we'll be back in
March and we come back in March it's
gonna be a little bit different a little
bit attenuated but don't worry we're
still gonna record for private podcast
episodes for our patreon audience so if
you're a patreon subscribers first off
thank you but also you will expect you
can expect regular podcast episodes
throughout the month of February we're
gonna do four episodes every Tuesday
we're gonna do one about products we're
doing one about happiness we're doing
one about branding and we're doing one
about gentrification which should be
fascinating because I've been doing some
research from some Urbanists and some
demographers who have been writing about
this topic and in some cities it's
actually way worse than what we might
think in some cities man you could only
hope for gentrification and let's talk
about the the nuances there and what are
the problems and what are the fo
problems of that in fact we're gonna do
that for each of these topics products
happiness branding and gentrification so
if you have questions about these topics
by the way we're happy to answer them
just head on over to the patreon and
leave them in the comments
but then beginning in March the
minimalists podcast the one you're
listening to right now the the popular
free public version will return with
30-minute episodes every week similar to
our current format we're gonna answer
your voicemails your questions will do
lightening around questions and minimal
Maxim's an added value segment and right
here right now we'll do listener
comments and tips we're going to
accomplish that in 30 minutes every week
the irony of this is a lot of people
have actually asked for that how do I
get shorter podcasts from you well
that's not the reason we're doing this
necessarily but it is one huge benefit
for folks who don't want an extended
conversation if however you do want an
extended conversation then you can join
us each week over on patreon we will do
60 to 90 maybe 120 minutes heck maybe
two hours plus some weeks depending on
how the conversations go if you listen
to last week's patreon conversation
you'll notice it was it was very
free-flowing it was very loose and Ryan
and I
man we talked about some stuff we
certainly would not talk about on this
main podcast feed just because well it's
kind of like a stand-up comic who is
testing out new material sometimes you
need you need the safety of a smaller
group a few hundred a few thousand
people instead of hundreds of thousands
of people before you can it's sort of a
gestation period for your workout your
material for the for the rest of the
world before you share it with the rest
of world so every week we'll do a
30-minute episode we're gonna call these
the minimal episodes and then each week
will record an additional long episode
an hour plus maybe even two hours plus
some weeks we're gonna call those the
maximal episode and those will be
exclusively for our patreon subscribers
and in those episodes we'll have sort of
the unrestrained freedom to dive deep
into our patrons questions about that
week's topic so we might the topic might
be about decluttering say and we'll do a
30 minute episode about that and then
we'll really dive deep and talk about
some personal experiences and some
personal struggles things that we
currently struggle with now as well just
for our patreon subscribers the maximal
episodes by the way will contain
entirely different content and material
from the minimal episode so there'll be
no overlap between them other than the
the topic itself we're also going to add
a new segment it's called more about
less each week during our patreon only
maximal episode Ryan and I are going to
read about a current event that ties
directly or indirectly to minimalism
then we'll share our opinions and
because we both have different points of
view Ryan and I think differently we
have different beliefs politically
spiritually emotionally sometimes we're
called the head and the heart of
minimalism will probably disagree and a
lot of the topics because of our
different points of view and that's the
best place patreon is the best place for
us to really disagree with each other
and I bet you don't mind if we argue a
little bit if mommy and daddy are
fighting as long as we hug it out
afterwards
right well we have more details coming
for you next month if you don't want to
miss that you can head on over to the
minimalists comm slash support that will
take you over to our patreon page or you
can just go to patreon.com/scishow and
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist this hey we're gonna talk
about baggage and I'm not talking about
luggage
oh man I I'm so glad we get to talk
about all my baggage today Ryan prepare
for the like the wrong episode he's
brought in like a bunch of luggage
sitting back here no I just got a list I
wrote down a list of all my problems
that I have that I've ever had I thought
today we've ever had yeah we're just
talking about all my baggage today right
or that stack of paper is well we do
have some questions about baggage
we're gonna talk about today and today's
first question is from ice and the
Philippines already Ryan Josh let's say
that you're not talking to someone
anymore
yes has that ever happened to you never
of course man of course there's a lot of
people in my life that well actually
that's not true that's not true they're
not in your life people who aren't in my
life anymore
well I'm trying to think of what I mean
of course Lee you know I've talked about
my father a lot on the podcast and how
we don't talk anymore but then of course
there are other people who are not in my
life anymore that I never went to them
and said hey you and I aren't talking
anymore is the last conversation we had
like I did that with my father like hey
look but this relationship is pernicious
I gotta let it go man
yeah and by the way if you if you want
to go all the way back to the parents
episode that we recorded you went into a
lot of detail and yeah it really opened
up on that
it was episode 145 yeah but there are
also people in my life where we just
don't talk anymore that maybe I do hold
a little resentment words like like I
want to call them up and you know give
them a piece of my mind or get one last
you know point and I don't know if you
ever get that at all man oh yeah
but like I think about and I'm not
gettin name names but Sarah John Doe no
man um
I especially think about in the
corporate world like there are people
who every once in a while it pops into
my head in like just things that they
have said to me in the past in ways that
they have belittled me or you know tried
to tear me down
I instantly get these thoughts of that
person's an idiot that person stupid
that person and I [ __ ] yet they're
wrong and I'm right in that that is a
very hard feeling to not perpetuate
mm-hmm but when I do feel that baggage
surfacing I get the same thoughts with
my dad too where it's like I such an
idiot if you would just hide it Ian but
I have to remind myself well I just look
in the mirror and like realize like I am
really imperfect like I I screw up a lot
yeah and I know that my my points of
view are not always the best points of
view they're not always the most correct
points of view or even when they are
they aren't they don't that doesn't
always remain constant either right the
thing that is right today that is the
right solution today may not be the
right solution a year from now a decade
from now and for me I found that to be
true with a lot of the the sort of the
relationships in my life whether it's
past intimate relationship past
friendships past co-worker relationships
the there were relationships that were
sort of right at the time but things and
eventually even yours and my
relationship will end yeah Emily ain't
none of my death
enough time line everything is ephemeral
yes and so everything ends in some
relationships in fact I would argue most
relationships in your life will end in
your life the weird thing is you don't
always know when it ends right just like
there I've heard Sam Harris talk about
this before
there is a last time that you will pick
up your daughter mm-hmm you don't know
when that is
but podcast Shawn has two daughters who
were both teenage high school girls and
I doubt he's still picking them up but
there was a time Shawn when you picked
up yeah Gaby for the last time and I bet
you didn't realize unless you threw your
back out or something cuz you were like
hoisting her buddy can't carry her
anymore
Shawn his ridiculous yes by the way yeah
yes he does I've worked out with Shawn
yeah he has an amazing deadlift
impressive coming from Ryan Nicodemus
who lifts all the weights at the gym Oh
keep going I've seen him they have to
bring in more weights these have all
been lifted oh my god anyway what I've
realized is that there is a last time
that you will pick up your child there
might also be there is not might be
there will be a last time that I talked
to you it it I it's hard to make me feel
emotional but just thinking about that
makes me feel emotional yeah like if
this is the last time I talked to you
that man that'd be crazy to me but there
will be a last time at some point like
that means that we need to appreciate
every conversation we have with each
other man you'd be thankful for the time
that we did have together so so to
answer Isis like that yeah to get back
to what she's saying is like having some
gratitude in fact I think one of the
problems right now with the baggage the
baggage is an expectation I wish it
would be this way I had hoped it would
turn out like this if it wasn't for this
my life wouldn't be this way right or
even if it's not something that is
that dramatic it could just be like I
really hope that X would happen but Y
happened this relationship and I had a
bad one if I replace that expectation
which is gratitude for how it happens
like that how it is I love that man
where so where I was going with was you
know me looking in the mirror and
realizing how imperfect I am I can look
at the people who I hold that baggage
for and I can say you know what like
they are they are imperfect they are
just as imperfect as I am right and
they're trying to deal with all their
imperfections also and I can I guess I
can just feel good about accepting that
I don't deserve anything which helps
with my expectations with which with
exactly what you're talking about
yeah so so the expectation thing is
often I deserve this from this
relationship you know what maybe maybe
you do deserve something but it's gonna
be from your own your own actions right
and so I always I always approach it the
same way you do Ryan I I'm not entitled
to anything from this relationship so if
I do get something from this
relationship if it's a positive
relationship that I can keep it going
however some relationships end in the
middle of your life some of them in
unexpectedly others you just have to
graduate from before you get that
divorce from them
and by the way you get divorces all the
time even when you don't know about it
if you break up with a girlfriend that
is a type of divorce sure right
in fact because you've made a decision
right the the word decision comes from
the same Latin root as incision which
means to cut off from and so if you're
deciding to end a relationship or
someone who has decided to in a
relationship with you they've decided to
cut off from now it doesn't mean you
have to completely cut ties with that
person I think back to my my former
spouse I have a better relationship with
Carrie now many years later than I did
when we
you were married now it took some time
and there was a valley of time where we
had to not communicate and and a lot of
emotions were involved yeah but that
time did heal the wound enough that in
fact it was much better after the
healing isn't that the truth with when
you get out of a a hospital or you break
a bone or whatever quite often after you
heal something you're better off than
before because you went through that
experience and some of it for me some of
my best experiences in life some of the
ones I'm most thankful for are some of
the hardest some of the worst
experiences in my life are some of the
best experiences of my life you can
tweet that ma yeah no it's absolutely
true man I mean when I think about like
the relationship with my dad for example
I am I am very grateful for being able
to let go of that baggage like I'm
really grateful to be able to move on
yeah and and again like anytime I think
cuz I do I'll get you know some some
emotion that gets drawn up oh man he's
such an idiot if he would just and then
I remind myself like he's not an idiot
he's imperfect like me he's dealing with
his imperfections and that doesn't make
him a stupid or anything else it just it
just means that he doesn't have a the
relate a relationship with him there is
not a place in my life where that is
going to fit and right now maybe you
with ice in particular but you you sort
of had to graduate from that
relationship and in order for it to
change now is there is there potential
for another relationship with your
father in the future sure but it'll be
different from what it was before you go
back into that and I think the say I
think about school as a good example we
all were in elementary school at one
point in time right but at some point
you you sort of you you graduated from
that and you may never see your
elementary school again Ryan yeah
probably not but you can still
acknowledge that it has a meaningful or
it was a formative experience in your
life yeah and you can appreciate that
like I'm glad I went through elementary
school it was a meaningful and
informative experience of my life mm-hmm
but it wouldn't make any sense now
for me to go back to elementary school
yeah and I think ice can look at the
relationship that way yeah and be
appreciative for what you actually got
out I think there's one more piece of
advice on any of ice that that's
important when I found myself not being
able to let go of the baggage meaning I
would wake up in the morning and I would
have this anger and it was towards this
relationship that I wanted from my my
father that I'm not getting I had to go
talk to somebody and sometimes you need
to go do that to help with the baggage
now the thing is is like I can talk to
you all I want about my dad and I really
enjoy talking to you and you're very
receptive and you always you know give
me a listening ear and you always help
me with advice sometimes sometimes you
need to speak to someone who well who
you trust but also who is kind of a
benign relationship so for me like going
and seeing a therapist getting a
recommendation from someone I really
really trust for them to say hey you
should talk to this guy he's a great
therapist he's helped me yeah yeah so so
now I have trust for that therapist and
I can bring them in and kind of get an
outsider's outsider's view it helps it
helps a lot so I see might want to
consider that also one of the things
that I've done in the past especially
when I first like embraced minimalism
and I was walking away from certain
relationships and then I was a year or
two years into it and this is so this is
before we moved to Montana sort of the
tail end of living in Dayton Ohio I
called a lot of those relationships and
acknowledged those people for for what
they were and so ice maybe this is one
of those relationships where you didn't
it wasn't a big divorce that you had to
walk away from there wasn't a big blowup
maybe there was just distance because
life happens and best friends become
strangers over time and so maybe what
you can do instead of just
feeling that baggage and wishing you
could read connect or maybe you don't
even want to reconnect and that was my
case there was some of these people were
well it wasn't like I was trying to
rekindle the relationship I just called
them and said hey I just want you know
you were a really important part of my
life for this period of time this month
this year this decade and I'm really
grateful for that and why we went our
separate ways it just happened or maybe
we had a fall out there are few people
I'm Leahey and you know we had we had a
crazy fall out you know we were stupid
kids I can't believe we did that and you
said some things I said some things it's
sort of water under the bridge at this
point I just want you to know I don't
hold a grudge against you and there were
even a few people that I knew I had to
apologize to yeah if there was something
I did that was egregious and even though
I didn't recognize it to be egregious at
the time as you mentioned you were all
imperfect and of course I thought that
you know whatever I thought was right at
the time right and there are few people
I had to apologize to and also a few
people I had to forgive yeah and I think
a forgiveness is the best feeling though
man
right you forgive people not for them
but for yourself quite often now it can
help other people as well in fact
sometimes the best way to forgive is
when they don't even know it sometimes
you have to forgive someone if they did
something to you in order for you to
move on in order for you to let go of
that baggage I said love to send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
it's the five-year journey of me and
Ryan as we went from the suit-and-tie
corporate guys to becoming minimalists
and then the minimalists and a lot of
that journey had to do with letting go
it sort of started with letting go of
the stuff right but and here's the book
Jordan's telling me to hold it up anyway
in the book it's actually it's my
favorite thing that we've ever created
anything we've ever written or created
and it's because it was sort of the the
first 30 to 33 years of our lives
crammed into 200 pages
and the lessons that we learned about
letting go and started with the stuff
but then it was letting go so much more
and also the lessons we learned along
the way and we accidentally picked up
some baggage along the way and hadn't
let go of certain habits that we had to
let go of we talked about a lot of that
and in particular there's a relationship
chapter in here called Harvest Moon and
I think you'll find a lot of value in
that chapter and the whole book so Shawn
if you could reach out the ice in her
the audiobook version or the book book
or the e-book if you'd like it's
available in all three formats and we'd
love to hear what you all have to say so
if you have a comment or a tip about
emotional baggage including advice for
any of our question askers today then
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode for this week's listener
comments and tips it's my favorite part
of the show so when you call in or you
send your voice memo just realize that
you can beyond the end of the show and
then maybe eventually if you're lucky
will steal your advice and repurpose it
appropriately alright Ryan with
Thomasson you know what time it is it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media did
we do were on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during the
lightning round so a Ryan and I each do
our best answer every question which is
a short shareable less than 140
character response we also put the text
of these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
quotes in one place over at minimal
Maxim's calm alrighty
our first lightning round question is
from Anna Anna wants to know josh is
sharing your emotional baggage with your
partner selfish what is a good balance
not only is it not selfish it's
necessary yeah and here's the thing you
know I am mister outstanding in fact uh
you know I've been feeling down recently
with some illness that's going on but if
I want to change my state I will go to
if I'm at the grocery store whatever
someone ask you how are you doing
mm-hmm we talked to Peter Rollins about
this last year but
the we asked how are you doing we don't
literally mean tell me about your
ailments right unless you're a really
close friend so with you or with back so
my my bed partner or my business partner
let you decide which one is which when
you ask me how I'm doing I am I'm honest
in a way that because I know you care
and you want to be updated because you
can either provide a solution or
sometimes the solution is just to listen
right you can help me out
help me find a solution or you can help
me by listening because as Peter Rollins
talked about love is giving what you
don't have to someone who doesn't want
it now my pithy answer for Ana here and
we can break it down a little bit
I put the answer that you can tweet is
sharing our pain with our partner is a
hallmark of love but we mustn't batter
our loved ones with our suffering yeah
so to me that it's it's sort of it's
it's both that there is over sharing now
if I were to come in here every day
around but my life sucks if I'm
complaining that's a problem I don't
complain to you I don't complain to to
backs I will tell you honestly if I am
in pain right if I'm struggling with
something because I know that you would
want to help but if I go to the grocery
store and someone asking how you doing
I'm gonna say I am outstanding no two
reasons I do that one is it makes me
feel better to say that because they're
not actually saying how are you doing
physically what are your ailments
they're saying hey howdy you're going on
yeah it's a simple greeting it's simply
saying hi right and for me to engage in
that conversation I also need to say hi
back in the most energetic way and for
me saying I'm outstanding increases my
energy and there was this absolutely
there was also this quote the second
reason I always say outstanding who was
it oh I think was George Carlin who said
to help you always tell people you're
doing great cuz it'll make your friends
happy and it will piss your enemies off
and well I don't want to piss anyone off
it does make other people feel good when
you when you say you're outstanding and
it also increases how good you feel at
the same time totally agree my short
answer would be this baggage weighs us
down only when we refuse to set it down
so I understand where Anna's question is
coming from here we don't want to burden
people with our baggage but but yes I
think specifically with our our not just
our romantic partner but just our close
friends close you know our family well
let's just say that the primary relation
yeah yeah we should take we should take
that baggage we should examine it we
should talk about it but if we hold on
to it too tight yes like we could bring
other people down and that's something
we want to do also Matt what we want to
do although sadly sometimes that's in
the moment misery loves company
so the misery that you're feeling will
encourage you to like pull up a chair
and say hey stay awhile cut comes to in
this misery with me
and that's why I find that complaining
does the opposite of adding to the
relationship because then you're asking
the person to suffer with you yeah in
fact when I was in the bathroom here the
other day here at our studio and I was
at the sink washing my hands there's two
sinks there and another guy walks up to
the sink next to me and first time I've
ever seen this guy in my life and he's
like I hate these damn sinks because the
water pressure wasn't great yeah and I
just looked I'm like I'm pretty sure
you'll be okay man
like it's like you still be able to wash
your hand it's just water fresh you're
like you don't even know me your first
interaction with me is complaining and
there's like this weird cultural thing
that's how we get in good with someone
is like well I'm miserable let me share
this misery with you anytime I can we
hate the same things right
what a terrible foundation to build a
relationship off a horrible foundation
yeah no III think it's important to
share to share your your baggage with
with yes not just your romantic partner
but yeah your primary relationships I
think the question that Anna needs to
ask you know
she asks what is that what is a good
balance the balance ana is if you are
complaining versus a seeking to to have
an open ear and there is a difference I
mean if we're honest with ourselves we
can kind of tell when we are just
complaining well that that's why I talk
about the pain versus suffering in my
pit the answer pain is not a choice
you're going to feel pain at some point
right you can choose how long you're
gonna suffer with that pain yeah amen
all right our next question is from Drew
do you believe emotional baggage can be
created simply by one's natural
personality and if so how would you even
start to change that well my short
answer is this before we let go we must
first loosen our grip amen I mean I can
think of times where I've wanted to let
go but I've clung to something so
tightly what's the David Foster Wallace
quote right everything I've ever let go
of has claw marks on it well it's so
easy meant like when I think about my so
going back to the lationship with my dad
like I could really use that as this
excuse to be a miserable person my dad
treats me like crap you know I have this
really bad relationship and if it wasn't
for that I could you know I could
actually do something with my life but
because I've got my my dad who refuses
to have a relation I mean I could really
get caught in that in that mindset and
well that is that is the opposite of
letting go right right and by the way if
you if you didn't have that excuse you
could search for another yes
always find another innocent you in the
problem Josh I think is sometimes there
are really good excuses there are really
good excuses even if it is a good excuse
though
like we still get it we still have to
let go of that baggage at some point
even the best excuse is still an excuse
yes absolutely that podcast Sean now one
of the things I'll say Ryan is it is
important so you have drew here saying
do you believe a motional baggage can be
created simply by one's natural
personality and what I would say is is
yeah I mean some people hold on more
than other
there are some people who have the
opposite of hoarding it's it's called
Spartan ism and it is also uh it's on
the same OCD spectrum as hoarding oh
where people like have to get rid of
everything and you know that and often
people confuse minimalism with Spartan
ISM as it disorder there's an other
there Spartans it's a totally different
thing but Spartan ISM is is this
compulsive need to constantly let go of
things and so what I've realized that
the middle ground is you sit sit with it
for a while right you don't have to let
go too soon because that's not actually
letting go you're letting go of the
motion immediately my mom died and well
I've suffered with it for 60 seconds
I've I've now moved on that's not
letting go well yeah that's repression
yes exactly hiding something yeah and so
you don't want to do that but you can
however loosen your grip over time and
it took a long time my mom died for me
to to let go with that and I would even
say that that's something I'll cope with
for the rest of my life or the maternal
relationship in particular is one that
you know I mean Freud had books and
books too to say about the maternal
relationship right and so that that's
something that is the most extreme
example but with other relationships
it's like okay I can appreciate that for
what it was but I need to loosen my grip
on that it's not as precious as I might
think it is absolutely ma'am
my pithy answer is this it's hard to
stay a victim when we go out of our way
to contribute beyond ourselves in a
meaningful way and what I mean by that
is I know for me the best way to feel
better is if I can go out and do
something for someone else because when
I have all of this pressure on me when I
when I feel like my life is out of
control the one thing I can do is I can
control what I do with my actions what I
can do with my time so maybe it's just
going out and taking someone out to
dinner or maybe it's you know
volunteering at a soup kitchen or
Habitat for Humanity or maybe it's just
I do I love like just when I'm at a
restaurant I'll buy two of whatever I'm
getting and then I'll just be walking
down the street I know I'm going to see
someone homeless on the
Sheeta no back here here's a ball here's
yet wait a minute we're now you can get
anything yeah it's true but no seriously
it's hard to like you said Josh it is
it's hard to do depressed when you are
doing when you're acting the opposite of
depressed yeah so so the only exception
to that are certain like autoimmune
issues or whatever of course but but I
think that that quite often we confuse
sadness with depression we walk around
this malaise and you're right Ryan we
can change that by by changing our state
and one of the best ways to do that is
to have a real purpose yeah and that
purpose is always beyond ourselves yeah
because I'm living just for myself than
I'm not really living at all do you eat
that Shawn anyone out there right now
who is in this depressive state yeah
like go out there and seriously
volunteer for a soup kitchen just one
day one meal just volunteer for one meal
there's some prep then there's like you
know when you serve the meal and then
there's some cleanup time so it's maybe
you know 2 to 3 hours for one meal yeah
but but that experience I just go try it
out and then if it doesn't work tweet me
but like Ryan I I'm depressed I tried to
go out and give a little piece of myself
and now I feel worse or I feel the same
let me know but I guarantee you that you
probably will feel much better about
yourself when you go home and go to
sleep that night
yeah or you'll learn that this is not a
way that is right for me to contribute
but you'll never know unless you at
least try it out right all right PS Ryan
we have two more questions for you Barak
asks what are some ways to turn pain
from our past into something that
nourishes us today I've got a really
good answer about this especially with
with respect to rebecca's in my
relationship I've turned a lot of past
pain and there's something the nourish
is not just me but our relationship but
then Lee also asks and this one really
resonated with me my mother died three
years ago
it calls me such heartache and
depression that I don't want to connect
with anyone else because I would rather
miss out then go through that mental
trauma again
and what baby steps can I take to get my
social life back and so man I've got got
so much talk about that because
obviously I've gone through the the
death of my own mother but also when you
go through that that trauma you you feel
like well you feel like you'll never be
able to connect with anyone again yeah
and I want to talk about this if you've
lost someone in your life as I have to
be your mother can be someone close to
you and maybe they're dead in a
different way
maybe it's like we could talk about your
father as well because he's not dead but
like your relationship is dead yeah
that's a different kind of dying so if
you'd like to hear our answers to those
questions you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalist private podcast that's right
every week we recorded an additional
podcast episode and it's available
exclusively to our patreon supporters so
if you want to support this show and
keep this podcast 100% advertisement
free then head on over to the
minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes
the minimalist private podcast feed
includes our ask the minimalist anything
episodes unreleased recordings of our
live events and the entire back
catalogue of past private episodes once
you become a subscriber you'll also
receive a personal link to our private
podcast feed so that it plays in your
normal podcast player you can find all
the details and all the good stuff
including an additional podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists comm
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode
I know for me the biggest pains in my
past past have to do with mistakes that
I've made in intimate relationships yeah
and it's not always like like burned the
barn down this was awful it was just
like oh I could have done that better
you know it's almost like going back in
a way watching the the game-day tapes
there's a reason that you know football
teams or basketball teams do that
because they realize like I did that
great I should do more of that you see
how we ran that screen perfect let's do
more of that let's figure out the recipe
there so I can do more of that oh can
you believe the way that I just left
that that when I was defending him I
left him wide open don't do that anymore
that's a mistake don't do this don't do
this don't do this and then pulling that
forward into new relationships okay now
it's time for our added-value portion of
the show this will read talk about
something that has added value to our
lives well you just say recently but
this is and this is something that's
recent I've listened to it recently but
we were talking about emotional baggage
today so I'm trying to think of like an
album I know when you you were like hey
man for today you uh we were talking on
the phone you're like hey man for
today's podcast episode try to think of
a recommendation of an album that gives
you emotion right that evokes some other
folks emotion and there was just the
oddest thing to hear coming from your
voice cuz because I know how you have no
feels right well externally I don't but
I you know my main emotion is
neuroticism yes no at Damien Rice who is
this Irish singer-songwriter he put out
an album in the 2000s called
oh just called Oh and it is it's
basically ten perfect songs it's it is a
perfect album it's definitely in my top
five albums of all time
and some of you might be familiar with
it some of you may not and if if you are
you're not go back and listen to it it
evokes a particular kind of emotion that
you you can feel what he was
when he was going through on this album
you can feel the pain the pleasure the
lust the the anger the happiness the joy
all in just a few songs and man it is
beautiful he his lisa hannigan on there
she sings backup on the whole album and
her voice is just angelic in a way that
perfectly complements him and his
songwriting the instrumentation is
usually really sparse but then it often
builds up into this this crescendo of
furious manic joy / anger it's
unbelievable and and you'll feel all the
emotions in this album if you just sit
with it for an hour it's damien rice
oh dude for me I think on the phone I
was joking around and I was like Pink
Floyd the wall done but it's funny
because like it actually that album
really does evoke a lot of emotion for
me like when I was in the eighth grade
they got that song on their mother and
it was like my mom had just attempted
suicide and you know SWAT team kicking
in our door so like I mean there's a lot
of stuff that resonates with me
personally but your childhood was was
like 13 seasons of cops yeah pretty much
me really was dude it really was but but
you know I think I think that was more
that's more personal and the wall is
such a cliche album like I think like
some people would listen to that and it
would evoke a different type of emotion
only because they've heard those songs
so many times it's become a meme of sort
yeah so the one I the the one that I
will recommend that everyone listen to
is it's by Joshua James and it's build
me it's build me this and like that that
album god man it just I mean there are
there are just certain points of wanting
to cry and then points of elation and
then confusion anger yeah everything he
does is such an excellent job of
covering a lot of different topics
whether it's war
or religion or you know his upbringing
yeah Joshua James is just one of the
most he's one of the most emotional
performers I have ever seen in my life
yeah you know I saw him my favorite
concert of all time was on my 29th
birthday I saw him in Kentucky Newport
Kentucky and he was playing in front of
a he's at a bar of like 40 people mm-hmm
and at first my my first thought was man
he he's playing like there are 4,000
people here yeah but that's not actually
what he was doing he was playing like
there was no one else at all in that
room yeah at one point I saw him on his
knees crying onstage and it was not an
affectation it's just who he is now we
have two degrees of separation from that
album in particular build me this was
produced by nate piper who didn't
realize that yeah i did the soundtrack
out of here yeah didn't the soundtrack
to our documentary minimalism dude i
didn't really see produced that yeah and
they have a children's album that is out
now oh wow i'm blank joshua james and
nate piper yeah that's crazy so good it
is so good I'll send you I'll send you a
link to it but yeah I gotta tell you man
I agree with you Joshua James his first
album is is more personal to me but
build me this is this emotional call to
arms and it is it's such a good album
and yeah I definitely check both of
those out all right let's move on to
right here right now so we talked about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist well what's going on with us
is YouTube if you want to comment on
this episode you can do so over at
youtube.com slash the minimalist also on
YouTube you could check out quicky
episodes of the podcast you can check
out living room conversations and much
more of less over at the minimalists com
you can also sign up for our email
newsletter over there you can get simple
Sundays new writings or new videos or
new things about simplifying your life
just go to the minimalists comm enter
your email address at the top if you do
that you also get all the show notes
anytime we put out a new podcast episode
they'll show up right there and your
email inbox will never send you spam or
ads or junk because that stuff is gross
Ryan what else you got for us I just
want to encourage people to read more
and get informed oh and here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi this is melody from
Cheyenne Wyoming I just wanted to thank
you for the work that you're doing
I came to your documentary at a time
when I was incredibly stressed in my
life and did not know what I was going
to do and your documentary helped me to
see that perhaps some of my stress was
linked to some of my stuff and all the
stuff that I had which was a lot and so
I read your your book everything that
remains and began to travel down the
road of a minimalist life and it's
really helped me have some clarity and
to understand my priority in my life
which is my family as a result of that I
went down to a part-time job I have much
less stress I have decluttered my entire
life and my kiddo is on board as well
and they can see that the benefits in
life come from experiences and other
things I did want to share a little bit
about how we help our daughter not get
so hooked up on the hook on the devices
we created a chore chart for her that
focused on developing relationships
learning new things and contributing to
the family as a part of her chores in
addition to other chores regular tours
are calling a friend having a 20-minute
conversation on the phone I'm doing a
craft planning the meal for the week
cooking the meal for the week and it's
it's the principles that I found through
minimalism that have helped us to really
look at the way we live our lives the
way we our relationship with each other
by husband and I in the way that we pair
it and the way we relate to our friends
and family
hi Josh and Ryan this my name is Carly
Bruce and I was in Selma California I
wanted to call in and just thank you so
much for all that you do and all that
you teach to others a few months ago out
of the blue a friend of mine that I
haven't spoken to in 10 years messaged
me and said I need to come see you for
some reason I have this feeling that I
need to come see you so she drove six
seven hours to come see me and she she
planted the seed about letting go and
how having all of the stuff that I had
in my house was contributing to my
anxiety and and mental clutter and all
of that and that led me to finding you
guys the the minimalist I don't believe
it was her that told me about it but
anyway started listening to your podcast
and your pithy answers while they may be
comical sometimes that's what makes them
stick and they can you guys were in my
head all of the time and and letting go
with of things and minimizing is so much
more than just throwing something away
or selling it there was one thing I took
out of my house and I just had to smell
electrifying feeling of oh my gosh I
feel so much better with this gone now
my grandmother who I just recently
realized was my mom throughout my life
obviously not biological but she
fulfilled that mom role where I've
always felt like why am I not worthy of
a mother well I I am worthy of a mother
I have always been worthy of a mother my
grandmother's been my mother I just had
to bury her on Memorial Day weekend I
got a lot of her stuff and I I can now
before I would have saved it all I can
now know that her memory is not in that
stuff her memories is with me so there
may be a few pieces
I keep her Marine Corps flag from the
ceremony's gonna be you know picture it
put in a frame and things like that but
most of the other things are going to be
sold or given to other people who
they'll bring value to hi this is
Jennifer from st. Louis Missouri I just
wanted to comment that as of last year
for the holiday season our family
stopped buying gifts for anyone under 18
and instead to avoid the holiday rush
and crush of the season I've taken a
week before Thanksgiving and written out
thankful and grateful news cards to my
family and friends instead so this
allows me to put a personalized message
telling them how grateful I am in very
specific ways and also gifts the gift
giving for the season done before all of
the quickness and craziness of the next
six weeks in sooth also a my relatively
recent listeners to the minimalist and
you've inspired me to start going
through some of my photos and this year
as a part of those cards I included old
photos that I had duplicates of in some
of my cards to my family and friends so
thanks for all that you do and I hope
this is helpful for somebody else out
there alright yo that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time minimus